cari amici e care amiche non cambiate
canale perché una sorpresa per voi avete
un canale youtube con tanti iscritti
oppure un blog seguito da molte persone
o magari nelle facebook star che non so
ancora quale sia la loro funzione nel
cosmo ma inspiegabilmente hanno un sacco
di persone che li seguono ottimo perché
quello che sto per presentare è fatto
apposta per voi palle così finalmente
avrete le palle per dire no no no vi
spiego brevemente come utilizzarle
comodamente da casa vostra
il vostro network col vostro manager vi
chiamano proponendovi di partecipare ad
una fiera che non è neanche il vostro
campo ma lo fanno per attirare gente che
loro vedono con un dollaro al posto
della fascia poi ovviamente siete
attirati dall'idea perché di
taglierebbero fior fior di soldoni ma
con le palle potrete dire no e la gente
festeggerà perché non ci saranno più
ingorghi causati dai vostri fan che
nella fiera se ne sbattono il cazzo
affrettatevi perchè l'offerta scade
domani anche se non è vero ma noi lo
diciamo perché probabilmente qualche
pirla ci crede
non lo so metti caso che tipo popolo di
scrivere un libro o di partecipare ad
una trasmissione televisiva come il
massimo esperto di qualcosa se tu sai di
non aver mai scritto una lettera di
auguri di natale e non sei un massimo
esperto di niente perché continuare a
farti prendere per il culo in un mondo
dove ti dicono che tu vali qualcosa
quando in realtà ti vedono soltanto come
una fotocopiatrice di soldi umana
tirando fuori le palle risolve questo
problema e con le prime 100 chiamate
regaliamo anche spina dorsale che se
usate insieme alle palle ci aiuterà a
prendere decisioni tu e soltanto tu
senza l'aiuto di nessuno cosa aspetti a
chiamare e sbrigati perché la gente
fuori dal web vi prende a pesci in
faccia dalla mattina alla sera
nessuno vi prenderà mai sul serio
le cose non cambieranno avete centinaia
di migliaia di iscritti perché fa nel
gameplay ottimo mi viene un dubbio
quando vi chiedono fai questa pubblicità
di orologi da donna ti paghiamo che
magari è il caso di non accettarla ma
perché dire sì quando puoi dire no sei
stato ufficialmente invitato alla sagra
della polpetta di pordenone no vuoi
diventare lo sponsor di un'industria che
fabbricarli da spedire medio oriente
no vuoi vedere questo film in anteprima
e poi parlarne in un tuo video
questo non è male per un video lo devi
fare mentre fai un po vino a satana no
voi non siete uomini voi siete
assorbenti li usano per che hanno
bisogno di voi
ma quando iniziate ad essere ingombranti
vi gettano nel bidone dell'umido non vi
sto dicendo che non dovete fare più
niente per il resto della vostra vita
perché ricerca non potete continuare a
fare video a 45 anni dalla cameretta di
casa dei vostri genitori ma c'è un
limite alle cazzate e questo limite si
può trovare soltanto usando le palle o
trovandoci un lavoro vero perché la
gente si dimentica di quelle opzioni e
lì ma c'è un lavoro vero e proprio ma
qui le care web star
tutti abbiamo fatto degli errori ma
perseverare è da stronzi oggi però le
inculate su dietro l'angolo